hey what's going on it's bill burn is
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I just checking in on you
how's it going as you can hopefully
immediately tell Celeste yeah if I just
push that button I I forgot my book I
didn't forget my recording equipment I'm
having a problem with one of the cords I
can't tell if the cord got stepped on
and it's [ __ ] up or the jack - my
computer's messed up but I've learned in
life to not force things because you
just make a bad situation a little worse
so I'm just going to record this one
like this and maybe Monday because I'm
on the road right now I'm out here in
Nashville Tennessee
Nashville Tennessee home of the Grand
Ole Opry and that [ __ ] River that
overflows in the the evil-looking
building downtown other than that
wonderful people great food and all that
type of [ __ ] I'm out here for one day at
one day only
I know you guys probably think of well
what the [ __ ] bill you didn't advertise
it on your goddamn website are you doing
a stand-up show I am NOT what I am doing
is I'm doing a panel thing for efforts
for family with the great Mike Price
co-creator co-creator of the show from
The Simpsons we're doing like a live
thing where they show an episode and
then we answer some questions
hosted by Russell Peters and it's going
to be on XM serious I don't know what
channel of course because I'm a [ __ ]
but that's basically what I'm doing here
and then I go off to Calgary tomorrow
morning Calgary Edmonton and then
Seattle so oh oh I got some stories for
you
I hope these levels are okay I did my
best with them um this was my plane ride
out to Nashville so we wrote all day and
then I took the red-eye out and the dude
who sat next to me on the [ __ ] plane
god bless him but he's one of these guys
man if he doesn't turn it around he's
not going to see 50 because he was one
of those guys who was abusing his body
so bad like I can't like when I go go to
his age it's gonna he was either like 26
to 28 or like 37 I couldn't tell
but he looked as old as me uh he looked
like he was if he was my age you're like
dude you guys like another two years
because if you [ __ ] did that to
yourself for close to 48 years you would
be done this [ __ ] guy man holy [ __ ]
he put on a display alright so you know
it's late at night and take the red-eye
like I said 11 p.m.
and I got the I'll he's got the window
right and fortunately my sciatica is
almost but gone away and I've just been
you know taking it easy and just sort of
actually working itself out while doing
all the stretches and all that [ __ ] so
anyways he's got the [ __ ] window seat
but I'm thinking I'm being smarter did
the aisle thing because alright if I
need to stretch I can just step out into
the aisle and I won't have to step over
anybody now because I [ __ ] up last
time with the st. Louis I please
Southwest and I wasn't thinking I just
went to the window seat and then I was
trapped you know on the other side of to
other people so this time I'm thinking
being on being smart but it turns out my
back feels great and now all I want to
do was go to sleep and this [ __ ] guy
man holy [ __ ] this guy was like crushing
the [ __ ] airport bar I don't know how
many [ __ ] Jack and cokes this guy
drank but he just kept going like the
guy would be so can I get another one
and then the guy would bring it over and
he'd be like my dude
thank you Freight the reason he said my
dude and then he would just be sucking
he sinks down and he was one of these
[ __ ] guys that was so out of shape
like he snored while he was awake you
know what I mean he did the noises this
guy makes right so after about I don't
know like [ __ ] five of these things
were in the flight I'm starting to nod
off he [ __ ] goes to step over me
mountain of a man goes to step over me
you know which of course soda wakes me
up and he goes into the
the bathroom and I notice he's wearing
his socks [ __ ] animal this guy is
like trying to kill himself from all
sides you know to me death comes from
the mouth but he's also trying to
[ __ ] speed it up try to go into the
express lane by bringing a little in
through the [ __ ] pores of the bottom
of his feet people it's not your fault
that you weren't raised right but you
got to look around in life okay you got
to do the [ __ ] math I almost think
what do you think it is grosser to be in
your bare feet are in your socks I know
initially the bare feet is work worse
but there's something about the socks
just absorbing it and like you know the
next day if you put them on again after
you took a shower you still got the
[ __ ] [ __ ] in because it's going into
your feet no matter what one of the
grossest things so the entire [ __ ]
flight this guy is just pounding Jack
and cokes I mean he had he must have had
like nine of them on like a I don't know
how long that's like it's like four
[ __ ] hours and I'm trying to sleep
and I can't get to sleep because you
know he's a big guy he's a cool guy he
was trying to step over you know one
point I did that Vietnamese gambler
squat and he's like he goes what are you
doing you praying over there you're all
right and I said no I got it I got a
sciatic nervous uni because I'll man
that's such so I couldn't get mad at him
because he was friendly but every time
he went to step over me he'd [ __ ]
wake me up and then I'd look and he'd be
going into the bathroom just wearing his
socks and it just was driving me [ __ ]
nuts so finally all I'm thinking is go
my god when this [ __ ] mountain of a
man goes down like he is going to snore
like I mean I've never had the
displeasure of sleeping next to Terry
Siragusa whatever's Tony Siragusa but I
imagined he was going to sound like
whatever that guy sounds like it like
two o'clock in the [ __ ] morning right
but it was a way to sing he was snoring
while he was awake but when he was when
he went to sleep he didn't make a
[ __ ] sound and oh he kept dropping
his [ __ ] iPhone
he had his shoes off just the noises he
was trying to make to try to pick it up
it's like why the [ __ ] would you do that
do that to yourself
these [ __ ] people that treat their
own bodies like a rental car I just
don't understand it it's like you can't
return this [ __ ] thing at the end of
the weekend you got to keep it this is
the vessel that's going to bring you
around for your [ __ ] life you know I
mean I should talk the way I [ __ ]
booze but you know I still do my jumping
jacks and I do a couple of cartwheels to
keep the stomach down you know so
anyways the flight [ __ ] ends my travel
is all [ __ ] up for whatever reason and
I'm basically by the time they booked my
hotel everything was sold out so I had a
hotel for the night but I couldn't check
in until 3:00 in the afternoon so I go
you know so they booked me in another
hotel and the person you know the travel
person goes so you got to check in at
this hotel you know at 5:30 in the
morning and then check out at 12 and
then check in for the other places it is
like at 3 p.m. it's like is that cool
and I'm like no it's not cool like do
you ever travel is that the way you set
up your travel you want to switch hotels
you know in the same [ __ ] city you're
staying but I mean I don't have any
choice so it's going to have to be cool
so I [ __ ] take a cab over there I get
to the places like [ __ ] 5:30 in the
morning
there's like planes trains and
automobiles right I get there and
they're like what's your under and I'm
like oh no I'm like bill burr they're
like antsy and like Williams and Rumple
[ __ ] still scared and I may not get
it right and the guy keeps going I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm like well I know
it's not your fault
so now it's like [ __ ] 5 in the
goddamn morning I got no place to stay
and he goes well the bellhop could take
you over to the [ __ ] Waffle House
right sorry if I make Mike no you are
going to move this laptop around I want
your [ __ ] here this thing okay yeah
I'm sorry if you know sorry about that
so the [ __ ] so now it's like [ __ ]
5:20 in the morning I got no place to
stay till 3:00 in the afternoon
I'm [ __ ] dead tired I couldn't sleep
because old fatty cakes over there was
drinking the [ __ ] Jack and cokes all
night stepping over on me with his
[ __ ] piss and [ __ ] infested soaked
socks and now they don't have a room
for me now I'm going to a Waffle House
right so I get to the [ __ ] Waffle
House you know at [ __ ] quarter to
6:00 in the morning half expecting to
see jay-z finishing the end of that song
you know that old [ __ ] thing go to
the Waffle House and we're going to do
it again I was [ __ ] it I guess he'd
be walking out with it right to Bangor
and then kick around at 7:00 well
Beyonce sings lemonade in the background
I don't know what the [ __ ] it is with
those two - I I don't pretend to know
I'm an old man anyway so I walk in
they're a bunch of [ __ ] characters
and I'm bleary died I'm not even [ __ ]
hungry but I know I can't just sit in
there like some sort of vagrant so here
are some eggs and a [ __ ] waffle and
I'm sitting there and there's this black
guy in there wearing his suit and he's
he's like an anomaly I don't know he's a
black guy but he isn't funny
[Music]
right everyone very rare you mean a
black guy who isn't funny this [ __ ]
guy is not funny
anyone shut the [ __ ] up and keeps
telling jokes he's laughing at his own
[ __ ] jokes and I just want to I want
to stab myself with my [ __ ] Waffle
House [ __ ] fork so at one point he
just won't shut up and then finally one
of the waitresses makes a joke well the
other way just the other waitress goes
you know don't walk out behind me you
know you don't want to you know you
don't want to basically [ __ ] with me and
then the lady goes on she goes I don't
fight pregnant women and she wasn't
pregnant okay what admittedly it was a
decent joke the unfunny black dude in
the suit you know high pitch left stands
up runs out of the Waffle House goes out
to the front and does like a [ __ ] 360
turn and immediately the did the [ __ ]
you know
the road-weary comedian and me going
like alright dude it was funny it wasn't
that [ __ ] funny and he comes back in
then I think what the [ __ ] to do I'm
like what the [ __ ] am I going to do with
myself I can't go to sleep my phones
running out of batteries I'm charging it
there it was just a [ __ ] nightmare so
I just started calling hotels they're
all [ __ ] booked up I don't know
what's going on here in Nashville
there's some sort of [ __ ] banjo
festival I have no [ __ ] idea but
there's no way some Jesus [ __ ] you know
or some you know Democratic a Republican
convention I have no [ __ ] idea but I
cannot get a room so you know I'm like
what do I do so I called him the Opie
and Jimmy show I talked to them for a
minute and then I was just like what am
i doing so I finally called a cab and I
just went over to the hotel that I was
supposed to be at and they were like and
they were like oh yeah you know somebody
called said you know [ __ ] last night
if we could get you in unfortunately we
cannot blah blah blah blah blah so I at
least checked my bags you know I felt
like a [ __ ] homeless person when I
was in the Waffle House with the unfunny
black dude and I had the [ __ ] bags on
the inside of myself as I sat in the
booth made the two [ __ ] people but I
was sitting there by myself right so I
get to the hotel I at least checked in
my bags and they had a [ __ ] like a
couch in the lobby of this place they go
we're already cleaning a room and at
this point it's 6:30 in the morning and
I'm like great whenever you can get me
in if I got to pay extra I just don't
give a [ __ ] right so they say fine so I
go over and I just lay down on the couch
put my hat over my eyes and I just pass
out I'm talking like I wasn't even
trying to be a gentleman I had both feet
up on the [ __ ] couch I was like this
is my bed and I'm just sleeping there
and I just keep hearing people they're
getting waking up getting on with their
day like you want a good some smokers oh
I hear they have such great eggs with
all this [ __ ] and then at one point this
guy walked by you know was [ __ ]
[ __ ] who whistled
[ __ ] keno I think I tweeted nobody
likes a Whistler at some point this
[ __ ] guy just came by whistling
you know just it's just some random song
it's not even it's not even a [ __ ]
song he's just whistling because that's
what the [ __ ] he does and then I just
completely I was just locked out and all
of a sudden I just feel somebody pushing
me once twice and I [ __ ] wake up and
then I go hey mr. Berger your rooms
ready I might thinking pause thank God I
thought it was like 7:30 in the morning
I looked it was like 10:15 I've been
sleeping out like a bum for like four
hours
so I finally ended up getting my [ __ ]
room and fortunately it was one of these
rooms that has the great curtains I was
able to close them and it felt like
midnight and I'm then I just [ __ ]
trashed woke up met some friends that
I've met along the way on the road and
took a drum lesson
I hate dropping names on this but like
they're one of my favorite bands out
there right now mute math is based out
of here and I got some lunch and Darrin
King actually gave me a little drum
lesson I still stink but it was [ __ ]
like I was beyond geeking out that I got
to do it so it was a bad day and I
actually ended up turning it around and
okay what's funny is if you notice from
the story I never flipped up bear with
me watch your ears I got to click and
drag this thing or just hang on a second
I apologize here we go here we go it's
almost over and it's over I just
realized I had no idea how much time I'm
doing here the [ __ ] does this mean here
447 448 for 248 one millimeters just a
metric system where the [ __ ] the timer
how do I tell them it's time I'm doing
all right you're just gonna have to
[ __ ] deal with this I apologize
anyways I got this weird thing when like
major [ __ ] happens
like I don't I don't flip out like
bigger [ __ ] like this I don't flip out
little [ __ ] bugs me like 20 minutes ago
I'm going down in the elevator and we
just hit every [ __ ] floor and every
[ __ ] floor is another person coming
on a [ __ ] full grown adults wearing
their name
a nametag around their neck like it's
their first day of preschool and
everybody knows everybody a car like the
shorts you wearing those to the meeting
is crazy write down one more floor every
[ __ ] floor it's getting more and more
packed and then I have to sit there and
listen to office humor right I'll tell
you right now if you think every once in
a while a random black dude in a suit in
a Waffle House isn't funny wait till
you're in a crowded elevator with a
bunch of people that sit in cubicles all
day they had the [ __ ] nametags around
the neck listening to their jokes for
eight [ __ ] floors like I was by the
time I got to the third floor I was
[ __ ] livid I was so [ __ ] angry
with the people around me could sense it
that when I went to get up the elevator
even women got out of the way so I'm not
proud of that but you would think I
would have flipped out at the big dude
stepping over me or I would have thought
this anyway so I would have flipped out
when my room wasn't ready I would have
flipped out you know even when I sent
the text message to my travel person I
didn't curse I didn't say that they
[ __ ] it up I know somebody [ __ ] it
up but I've learned in the past to not
just slice the head off for the first
person I just went very like you know I
don't know what happened but this is not
acceptable people knew I was coming here
for two months I don't understand I've
never had this problem before this can't
happen again
I'm now on my way to a Waffle House it's
5:21 in the morning with all of my bags
and I just you know what what else do
you need the [ __ ] SEC right so
anyways it all ended up working out and
I got some blade food out here and I
ended up running into one of the cast
members of Nashville which is my wife's
favorite [ __ ] show unfortunately just
got cancelled and I ran for the guy
Charles esten
and he was the coolest [ __ ] guy I was
like oh my god my wife loves your show
is there any way I could get a picture
and he goes now put it on video because
watch this because you do the intro he
was so [ __ ] cool so I just was like
Amy yeah well I'm in Nashville I ran
into one of the locals and it turns in
it's his face he just goes hey Nia
thanks for watching the show she freaked
out
I got some good points so thank you to
Charles making my [ __ ] make it my
married life a little easier so well so
there you go I don't know how much time
that took up according to GarageBand I'm
at five hundred and forty something 540
[ __ ] of these oh they counting the
little things was at 540 seconds
am I really supposed to do that math and
I have I not done ten minutes yet 600
seconds is 10 minutes now Jesus I don't
know I'm talking about this point sorry
I gotta click on this thing here it's
not let me do it alright here we go a
little little advertising here all right
zip recruiter everybody are you hiring
do you know where to post your job to
find the best candidates posting your
job in one place isn't enough to find
quality candidates if you want to find
the perfect hire you need to post your
job on all the top job sites and now you
can next please mention the talking
points below well why wouldn't I you
wrote them I'm going to read them with
Jeff recruiter com you can post your job
to 100 plus job sites including social
media network networks like Facebook and
Twitter all with a single click find
candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zipper
crew is easy-to-use interface no
juggling emails or calls to your office
quickly screen candidates rate them and
hire the right person fast find out
today why zip recruiter has been used by
over 800,000 businesses and right now
list my my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free by going to zip
recruiter comm slash Burke that zip
recruiter comm / / hey zip recruited
comm / / alright track her smash a
smartphone smart homes technology has
made everything like wicked might do but
losing your stuff still makes my people
feel really stupid
he's wicked stupid tracker makes losing
things a thing of the past tracker is a
coin size to both device that locates
misplaced keys wallets bags computers
anything in seconds
pear tracker so yes my phone attached it
to anything and find its precise
location with the tap of a button it's
that easy lose your phone press the
button on track and your phone rings
even when it's on silent silent silent
sorry
with over 1.5 million devices tracker
has the largest crowd GPS network in the
world so your lost item shows up on a
map even if it's miles away never lose
anything again with tracker listeners to
this show get a special discount of 30%
off your entire order go to V spelled th
e TR AC ke r comm the tracker comm enter
the promo code bar the hardest thing
you'll ever have to find is their
website go to tracker the tracker calm
right now and enter your promo code bar
for 30% off your entire order again hey
that's the tracker B tracker comm promo
code death and lastly but hopefully not
okay lastly but not leastly re-boil and
branch
oh sorry ball and branch oh I don't want
the feel ll and Blanche
alright as you set out to improve
yourself there is one simple thing you
can do every day to help you be in your
best to be your best in every situation
that's getting a good night's sleep
Jesus Christ lord knows I never do it
fallen branch delivers the rest you need
wrapped up in their super comfortable
luxury linens and they do it right with
the first bedding company to be
Fairtrade certified which means that
your sheets come from the work of happy
hands not crying children and sweatshops
in beautiful packaging made entirely
from recycled and sustainable materials
you can only get their sheets in one
place that's full and brand calm where
you know you're paying for quality and
not department store overhead you're
getting thousand dollar sheets for just
a couple of hundred bucks go to ball
that's B Oh L L and branch calm and well
let you let you try them risk-free for
30 days if you don't love them you can
send them back you have nothing to lose
and it gets even better go to ball and
branch calm today for twenty percent off
your entire order sheets towels blankets
duvet covers everything plus four
shipping and all their products come
beautifully packaged in the signature
boxes go to ball and branch calm today
for 20 percent off your entire order and
use promo code per ball and branch calm
promo code bar and mercifully that's the
end hey I got to ask you guys a question
here and I apologize for all the
extraneous [ __ ] noises that's the
right word for I went into the the
drugstore out here because I forgot my a
leaf the celts outline flames sciatica
here and sciatic nerve I should say and
I went in there and there's this
campaign that red-nosed [ __ ] fun thing
whatever it's all these some sort of
charity and it's all these [ __ ]
people famous people wearing the red
nose so I'm going what the what is this
I keep seeing this so I start reading
the box and it says Walgreens will
donate 100% of everything that they gain
collect or whatever so this red nosed
Camp Red Nose fund 100% is going to this
Red Nose fund so I'm like alright what
is it what is the fund nowhere on the
box will it say what the [ __ ] it is it
doesn't say when it's raising money for
nowhere on the buck so I asked the lay
buying the counter and I go so what is
this for if I buy one of these red noses
what is this for she goes on you get one
of these and it was like a little
[ __ ] gift certificate off a [ __ ]
chapstick or something I don't know no
no I don't like what I get if I buy a
red nose like where did the money go
Who am I helping out she goes oh I don't
know it's like my first day and I just
laughed I was like well I'm gonna start
the [ __ ] green hat fund and
everything's going to go to me she's
sort of like I guess half-assed laugh I
should have talked to the black guy in
the suit in the [ __ ] waffle house he
would have ran out of the place I'm 15
cartwheels and come back in code it's
not that funny I'm telling you my that's
the new I'm not saying the Red Nosed
thing is a scam but it's pretty [ __ ]
shifty
jadi then I'm sitting there looking at
all these celebrities and it's just the
Red Nosed fund and there's nothing on
there saying where the money goes you
know is it shouldn't that red nose thing
bring up a couple of red flags do I
think that that's the new there's two
new things going on in this country
they're actually generating income for
people the legal selling of weed at the
state level and nonprofit nonprofits is
like the new hardware store like back in
the day you had to open a store and
actually sell [ __ ] and nowadays you can
just start [ __ ] with come up with a
mirror a mirror
a ribbon a [ __ ] wristband a red
[ __ ] nose and people dump ice water
over their [ __ ] head whatever it is
you know some of them are legit I got
this feeling most of them aren't and I
kind of feel like if you're old like me
and you remember the late 80s when all
those televangelists were on TV and they
went to like this national [ __ ] level
and they just made hundreds of millions
of dollars before it all just came out
that it was just this giant [ __ ] cash
grab I feel like all those [ __ ]
nonprofits it has to be going in that
direction and how all these sporty
sports leagues get in bed with all of
these [ __ ] people I don't know maybe
they have enough money maybe you have
enough money to keep it silent but uh I
don't know I'm kind of done I get money
to st. Jude's Hospital that's it
everything else I just I don't have the
[ __ ] time to figure out whether or
not you're a [ __ ] scam or not because
I gave to that Wounded Warrior [ __ ] I
gave so many I gave so much [ __ ]
money I used to donate like 10% of the
[ __ ] I made in the advertiser to those
[ __ ] people and then people started
sending me these these articles and the
next you know they get investigated and
all that type of [ __ ] and I don't even I
just stopped following the story and I
just stopped giving the money cos I
don't know I don't know if it's true or
not I don't even [ __ ] want to know
but like I just feel like the future of
helping people out is literally walking
up to a wounded warrior like
finding out where the [ __ ] they live and
be like what do you need go out and get
it or you raise the money and then you
give it to them but then if I raise it
then do I become one of those people be
like oh we had a little bit of overhead
and all of a sudden I have some sick-ass
drum room and I just bring a [ __ ] box
of band-aids to a [ __ ] veteran I mean
that's the change like what Ollie I
don't I'm a cynical son of a [ __ ] but
my new [ __ ] is I want to just I still
love doing charities I love doing
benefits I did one the other night for
like a [ __ ] it was like a private
school it's like it's a [ __ ] private
school like you guys don't need money
it's like always for the people can't
afford it it's like is it who knows what
it is you're just saying what it is and
then was and all of a sudden they who
gets the money where does it go where
does that person go are they in Tahiti
are they helping somebody out nobody
[ __ ] knows it's brilliant [ __ ]
brilliant I hope that Red Nose things is
on the label it's on the labels on the
level sorry I didn't get a good night's
sleep you know those Hotel couches I
mean what they [ __ ] used to be there
I honestly have no idea how much time
I've done here I'm not so like 838 of
these seconds here I'm just gonna say
this second right let's see here is 600
seconds in ten minutes so that means
they'd be 1800 seconds and a half there
is no [ __ ] way that's only a second
what if it's two seconds I got to be
coming up on my face two seconds [ __ ] it
it's two seconds so all I got to do is
just make it up to 900 and I get another
49 to go oh [ __ ] it easy let's talk a
little playoff hockey everybody anybody
watch Heat mission just how busy I am I
keep missing that that Tampa Bay
Pittsburgh series I caught the end of
[Music]
Game three where the Penguins were up
and then a game a couple of right there
spreads to put it out of reach and I
[ __ ] sent a buddy of mine in
Pittsburgh
congratulating them because as much as I
don't like what the Penguins cheap-shot
artists have done to the Bruins you know
I don't take it to the level that I
don't want my friends teams to win so I
said congratulations and the second I
spent at Tampa Bay scored one it felt
like a jinx them for half a second but
I've been watching the Blues in uh in
San Jose Shaq and this is [ __ ] huge
tonight for the Blues because San Jose
obviously adjusted to whatever the [ __ ]
the Blues were doing in Game one
and so now balloons have to adjust to
whatever San Jose was doing because San
Jose pre dominated pretty much
wire-to-wire the last game and I don't
know it's making me nervous as a as a
total bandwagon blues fan they obviously
got to win this one that's such a stupid
thing to say this business it's just one
a big one bill should they not go down
three games to one you [ __ ] dealt big
shoutouts all the soccer fans over there
in Europe that got so [ __ ] annoyed at
everything that I said I shouldn't talk
about sports over in Europe you guys all
make a great point because I don't watch
him and I don't know anything about them
but what you fail to understand is how
much I enjoy irritating the [ __ ] out of
people that I've never met before so I
stand by what the [ __ ] I said you guys
should have some sort of in the Premier
League you should have a [ __ ] playoff
playoff the fact that somebody can win a
[ __ ] championship because another
team came to like a tie and like that's
it
just imagine every [ __ ] movie about
soccer it's always there's the big
[ __ ] game right and then somebody
comes down and scores a goal it's not
like the stars of the movie standing
around waiting for somebody to [ __ ]
you know have a 1-1 tie with somebody is
this sitting there in [ __ ] street
clothes or sitting in an apartment doin
jello shots with each other I know I'm
just [ __ ] with you I know member that
Sylvester Stallone movie victory ended
them with them walking away from the
game
no they were gonna do it they wanted to
escape and then they came back because
they wanted to beat the guys and if that
was actually based on anything real the
game would have ended and then they
would have won they would have been
brought back to the prison camp and they
would have been beaten to death but
instead what ended up happening was they
came back and they beat the Nazis these
prisoners allied prisoners of war and
then they [ __ ] they just walked out
with the crowd that stormed onto the
field and gave them extra clothes and
[ __ ] I don't know I'm sure it was based
on a true story but uh I've seen enough
of the Germans in their respect for life
outside of their own country for people
who earned on German I think that they
would just opened up on the crowd so I'm
calling [ __ ] that movie was called
victory by the way by the way it was a
great I actually really enjoyed that
movie but it was when I first got cable
sentinels
[Music]
anyways is that as at a half hour I'm up
to 962 seconds or 1800 I have no [ __ ]
I did you know what I'm going to find
out here because I'm gonna have to do
the Monday morning podcasts like this
one also and my timing will be a little
bit better on the next film because I'll
know exactly how much time I'm doing I
just don't understand why this good
[ __ ] thing them tell me how much time
but I'm not gonna start hitting buttons
and it's going to be irritating to you
if you listen to it on the [ __ ] we've
had fun so anyways that's it
so that Thursday afternoon podcast just
checking in on you hope you [ __ ] have a
great weekend and here's a little bit of
music and enjoyed the clips from
podcasts from years gone bald and of
course likes talking anywhere there it
is
[Music]
you
hey what's going on it's bill burr it's
the Monday morning podcast and a gloomy
rainy depressing Monday morning here in
Los Angeles
probably days are extra depressing out
here because it's usually sunny and it's
what you expect out here feel like I'm
going to go into a Karen Carpenter song
thirty days alone there's always catch
me down really is that a reason to stop
eating I don't think it is Wow Wow I
just started off real mean midnight
well well [ __ ] well who gives a [ __ ]
it's a gloomy Monday and I attacked it a
dead ant erectus
how you like that that's how I start the
Monday morning podcast so there you go
if you're new to my page I do want to be
every Monday morning
did I say Monday oh did I say run day
every Monday morning I do a podcast and
evidently I attack some defenseless dead
person that's how I started off only if
it's overcast if it was sunny it would
have I would have a completely different
plot but basically I do one of these
every Monday and I answer questions that
some of my 14 listeners send in lately
I've been giving out advice peoples and
asking the advice and sometimes I ask
questions and hopefully in the end of it
nobody learns anything and you know
you've wasted 15 minutes of your life
that's what I'm trying to do and
speaking of wasting 15 minutes of your
life I am actually sitting in my
apartment my little villa and really
made me sound like I had a pool boy
didn't my little villa here and I'm
waiting for a plumber and you know I
don't to judge the guy because I never
met him but this [ __ ] this guy
was supposed to be here at 9 o'clock in
the goddamn morning all right it's two
minutes past the hour of 10 o'clock now
I don't know what time zone you live in
what world you're in but in my little
neck of the woods 1002
mount's 1003 it just turned
my cable box it's [ __ ] 1003 1003 is
not 9 o'clock and goddamnit I want some
answers I'm going to read a ball my hand
up into a fist and [ __ ] pound it on
my coffee table like like some like that
guy in the spider-man comic books who's
a loser guy at the Daily Planet
Jameson huh with his [ __ ] it's such a
weird way of going great didn't he just
the side of his head turn white all the
way around and then on top it was jet
black and you'd always be chomping on a
[ __ ] cigar you know just I don't want
to tax family but you know it's really
you know I got it he's the boss all
right what am i doing okay
all right let's let's [ __ ] and get back
to this let's get down to brass tacks
here okay why am I waiting for a plumber
I'll tell you why wait for a plumber
because for some reason my sink when the
water comes out lately
it smells like swamp ass I don't know
what it is there's definitely a funk
coming out of my sink and it's not
coming out of the kitchen sink so I've
ruled out some sort of outside sources
obviously you know because it was coming
from the street the main water line I I
think whoever would be [ __ ]
everything if we coming out of
everything right now do I have any
plumber listeners out there you know can
you help me out because evidently this
[ __ ] is not showing up it's 1004 and
he's still not here see you know this is
why the United States of America is
starting to lag behind China and all
that that in China when you call a
plumber 48 of them show up it's [ __ ]
858 begging you then you have a wrench
you know what I mean somebody just
[ __ ] bikes down the pipe and three
other guys just start spinning the guy
around you know but not in America I got
away for this [ __ ] to show up
I'll pay what sucks too is I don't know
if they act stupid but it just that that
that makes it hurt even more is when
they you can't figure out how to fix the
sink and then some guy comes up mobile
the pole ring you know this [ __ ] ass
hanging out he knows how to fix it
that's why I started to become handy
okay because I actually sat down and I
analyzed it the other day and you know
fixing a sink is not a gift you know I'm
saying it's a skill it's something you
learnt inventing the sink okay or the
toilet like that that guy Eddie crapper
whatever his [ __ ] name was all I know
is his last name was crapper okay
because of him we don't have to [ __ ]
outside and what's what thanks does he
get his last name becomes slang for
taking a dump tell me he didn't die a
bitter rich man Jesus Christ you know
some people man it's just you know they
do such good and what did they get out
of it huh Jesus Christ I mean I bet you
and your last name was crapper every
female in that family could not wait to
get married and just get away from that
goddamn last name I mean they probably
took the first thing that came down the
pike that'd be a great thing to google
and go check out the amount of women
with the last name crapper that married
the first trucker that [ __ ] fingered
him on a [ __ ] Tuesday night Jesus
Christ just because they were shameful
of them their maiden name was probably
led to some sort of child abuse and
alcoholism and that's probably another
reason why it's 10:06 and the [ __ ]
plumber still isn't here I really hope
he shows up halfway through this okay
because you guys can watch me give this
guy a piece in my [ __ ] mind and I
won't curse either so we can't leave
what is he doing okay people - what's he
doing huh she driving you know we got a
van you know if you're a carpenter you
get a pickup is here if you're a plumber
you got a van you know because in case
it rains you can't have it stolen the
pipes and they get all rusted I don't
know why well what is he doing Hansie at
the army/navy store buying some more
Dickies you know so they do what do they
trade their underwear for their Dickies
for their [ __ ] crack of their ass is
hanging out 10:07 okay anyways yeah
that's the deal I started to learn how
to fix [ __ ] okay I've fixed the leaky
faucet the other day which is
unbelievably easy but it makes no
goddamn sense
you [ __ ] take the handle off and
there's this little rubber stopper with
this spring in there and that's all if
you take it out you stick the
[ __ ] back you pick a new one in
there and magically it stops leaking I
don't get it it's not like it's in the
pipe I have no idea why it works but it
works and I went on the internet within
three seconds I learned how to do it
okay my ass wasn't hanging out of the
back of my pants and I didn't charge
somebody [ __ ] $200 and I was on time
damn [ __ ] okay so anyways I do
one of these things every single week
and people ask me questions and I hide
upcoming gigs like the fact that I'm
going to be at this week I'm gonna be at
a Zanies in Chicago and actually
downtown Chicago on the 14th and 15th on
the 16th I'll be in st. Charles and on
the 17th I'll be in Vernon Hills
Illinois and I got to tell you something
I really really enjoyed doing this gig
especially to downtown Chicago this nice
small I mean looks like a walk-in closet
the place is so small and I don't know
man it's like an old-school comedy club
and all these old comedy photos they
just left them up like so it's like a
[ __ ] Museum I love the place and I
always have great shows there so and I'm
going to the Cubs game on the 15th baby
be like my third fourth time going to
Wrigley Field you know Here I am
bitching about a plumber I really ought
to count my blessings here go into a
[ __ ] Cubs game this week ok and
continuing on on the 29th May 29th
through June 1st I'm making my
triumphant return to New York City
Caroline's comedy club I got a whole
brand-new hour last time I was out there
I taped my my one-hour comedy special
which I have information about that I
will be giving out later on in this
podcast look at me look at me teasing it
a little bit making you stick around huh
don't know your eyes at me I know what
I'm doing when I'm playing the [ __ ]
game
let's see in what else we got here then
you go into June and actually forgot
about this date I thought I had a couple
a couple weeks off after Caroline's but
evidently not I'm going right back out
to Raleigh North Carolina good night's
comedy club how the [ __ ] did I have a
date there man I'm turning 40 on the
tenth I plan on coming home on the
second getting into the fetal position
doing some crunches and not eating any
carbs until June 10th when I turn 40
god damn years old but now I have to fly
across this country and go to Raleigh
North Carolina the desolate the
frightening Raleigh North Carolina B
what the [ __ ] happened to the downtown
area so you know it's a beautiful part
of the surface of the state during the
day Raleigh North Carolina
downtown I'm not talking about NC State
and he stayed that that place is nice I
actually went there for two semesters in
87-88 inch one in a while he went there
for two semesters go online in Google
silber's [ __ ] NC State uh [ __ ]
transcript and you figure out why I left
after that but the downtown area that's
one of those downtown's where you know
you could tell at some point in the past
the history it was it was a place it was
hopping it was jumping still making
their own moonshine down there right and
then you know what happened you know
what I bet the what the dreaded Walmart
that's what happened
they built a Walmart then they then they
made a mall the Crabtree mall is that
what you guys go in the whole downtown
area just it's a [ __ ] ghost town past
601 in the evening and I'm just left
down there by myself downtown in the
[ __ ] hotel I hate it
I need people around me on the city
person goddamn people I'll [ __ ] leave
and then I'm down there and I got to go
out and hail the cab and Allsop is just
homeless people it's like that [ __ ]
what is that movie 28 days that's what I
feel like I mean I'm still having a
zombie movie so if you're working
downtown Raleigh and you're going to go
to one of my shows why don't you hang
out of work just hang out
and go straight to the clubs when I walk
out to get cab I can actually see
another [ __ ] human being that looks
like they don't have hepatitis all right
and the next gig I am coming up is June
19th through 21st I'm going to be at the
punchline in Atlanta that's another one
of my favorite comedy clubs look at that
Janey's Caroline's good night punchline
Atlanta I like all of those clubs I like
all of them they're just good clubs good
clean fun and I'm going to come in there
with my potty mouth June 19th through
the 21st and I don't know I've been to
Atlanta a lot lately so I'm hoping I'm
going to start to build the following
out there I always seem to get a good
turnout and I got a whole nother Nuala
for you you sons of [ __ ] and then
after that you guys you're on your own
just go to my website you can click on
it right there if you're looking at my
MySpace page I managed I imagine most of
you are secretly listening to this in
your cubicle and you probably reduce the
window is that what you did and now you
sitting there looking at what do you
look at in a cubicle how are you looking
at spreadsheet some sort of counting
thing with with assets and liabilities
and you're rubbing your chin is if
you're not listening to me huh well
that's good you know what I think that's
a good thing you know you should do
today you should take a magnet run it
right down the back of your boss's
hardware it's not as Hardware his
[ __ ] hard drive that's what you do
and if he walks into the office right in
the middle of you doing that what you do
is you smile big open smile which causes
his defenses to go down and then you
swing that magnet at him like a [ __ ]
Chinese star and either right in the
forehead now the great thing about
knocking somebody out is as far as I
know as far as my experience with
getting knocked out is you forget the
previous three minutes so as long as you
fire that [ __ ] magnet at him before
the three minutes are up he won't even
remember what happened but the key is is
to do it in a manner before he can be
like you know yell your name and say
what are you doing in this office you
know
jennipher [ __ ] whatever I'm so bad at
coming up with so picnic goddamnit
Jennifer will go with Sullivan there's a
[ __ ] basic name that's why I can't
write scripts the story's always good
but my [ __ ] name you know the hero's
name Joe Smith William the worst so I
can never commit crime and never to come
up with a good alias what's your name
Bob Bob what Avenue all right Robert why
don't you get in the back of the [ __ ]
car but I didn't do anything all right
let's get on the have I ever been
arrested yes yes I have yes I have is
interested drinking and driving back in
December of 1989 and if you'd like to
hear more of the story tune in next week
um oh wait a minute what did I say oh I
know that's right I'm going to tell you
guys and when DVD is coming out uh but
first we're going to answer some of the
some of the questions that people have
asked me here's a question I might have
answered it before
okay podcast question number one a this
is how many I have actually went into
some old emails and I found a bunch of
other ones so that I didn't get to so
who knows there we go
question one a bill have you ever
thought about going to Iraq to entertain
the military I served in the Gulf War
and we liked having entertainers come
see it if you have art if you have
already gone what was it like for you
you would [ __ ] kill no I have not I
have not done over there for the simple
you know the only way I would go over
there is if I went through six weeks of
boot camp first like you did and you
know they gave they taught me how to
[ __ ] kill somebody you know I'm
saying that's like not knowing how to
swim and then doing the [ __ ] you know
entertain some people on a tugboat
during during choppy water you know what
I mean that could be honest with you I
would love to go to Iraq but I'd love to
go over there when it was [ __ ]
peaceful and experience the culture over
there when the
are no insurgents and yeah that's the
thing you don't I mean I know they fly
into the [ __ ] base and I'm surrounded
by a bunch of Marines and that type of
[ __ ] but you know I just watched too
many Will Smith movies where he's the
only guy left and I don't know how to
fire a gun so uh you know I don't have
that kind of boss like Bob Hope will go
you know he went all over Vietnam was
like a [ __ ] golf bag in an umbrella I
guess he never died right maybe that
should be you know but you know what
chaos theory I don't think he'd get
killed on the base but you know I'd be
one of those guys yeah [ __ ] you know
the plane I was in would get shot and
some everyone the plane would survive
but I fall at the bottom through the
goddamn look I'll entertain the troops
okay I've done it a bunch of times but
I've done it over here I don't I don't
do away games I'm like Roger Clemens
when you play for the Astros okay I'm on
steroids I'm cheating on my wife and I
don't [ __ ] pitch in Iraq lobby
honestly I'm terrified to go over there
there you go okay that's why you're a
[ __ ] marine and I'm a civilian and I
respect you and you know I'll [ __ ]
you can listen to these podcasts in Iraq
you know I mean put them over to my
[ __ ] Chuck Norris to me in all the
senses because I know the balls to go
over yeah that's basically it yeah I'd
want to go over there and then somehow
get kidnapped and end up being you know
rocking back and forth gently in an
orange jumpsuit is there you know
they're reading [ __ ] about a lot and
then they saw my [ __ ] head off and
I'm really sitting there going like hey
you know what why did I come over here
okay moving on question number one that
was one a okay did you do a voice on
grand theft auto 4 there was a biker
dude that sounds just like you if it
wasn't you you got to check it out
actually yes I did I did do a voiceover
on that and it was a big thrill to do
that and I got to give a big thanks to
to Laszlo hooking me up
and Jimmy Norton so hooking me up with
the Opie and Anthony show because that's
how I met Laszlo and that's how I got in
there
the war's over yeah that works question
number two I noticed you have
Strikeforce MMA in your top friends I
was wondering who are a couple of your
favorite MMA fighters that's just a
friend I accepted and then I guess they
switched their picture mixed martial
arts
I don't know I do watch that i watch flu
i watch i watch the UFC fight i watch i
watch their reality show which of course
i can't remember the name of the
Ultimate Fighter this this season where
they have to fight their way just to get
into the house and what the [ __ ] his
name they're the junkyard dog getting
them [ __ ] confused with old time
wrestlers who's the guy who knocked out
Chuck Liddell the [ __ ] guy who goes
out and then kicks the [ __ ] out of you
where's the chain and [ __ ] you know
beats the [ __ ] out of people Randy
Jackson yeah and then the other guy with
the [ __ ] you don't want to [ __ ] with
me cauliflower ears you know I actually
have a theory that if you just say you
don't even need to get the black belt if
you just have some somebody box your
ears and you get those cauliflower ears
no one's going to [ __ ] with you in a bar
because they just look at those [ __ ]
up ears those exploded vegetable ears
and they're just like that guy could
[ __ ] snap my neck choke me out and
give me a Superman punch with a flying
knee all at the same [ __ ] time
so I even answer the question who are
some of my favorite ones I like Matt
Serra I love the [ __ ] he talked about in
what's-his-face was st. Pierre that's
the kind of shape I would like to be in
for my 40th birthday that evidently I'll
be contemplating in downtown Raleigh
North Carolina all right you know what
this podcast is starting to seem long so
when we gloomy blow through these next
[ __ ] questions all right number three
bill did you hook up with any of the
stewardesses at the airport from last
week's podcast oh yeah yeah I've hooked
up with all three of them and they we
had a [ __ ] foursome right out in the
open you know and that didn't violate
any new [ __ ] Patriot Act now I I
didn't and thanks for bringing that up
okay I know I was going to go up and say
what's up to him but there was something
about their blue pantyhose that just
really found it intimidating question
number four I was wondering since you're
such a big such a bug sports fan a big
sports fan what is your best sports
memory from your childhood
uh well [ __ ] dad let's go with something
funnier then how about here's my best my
best well okay the good sports memory
when the when the New England Patriots
beat the the Los Angeles Raiders what
was it 1985 the year we got we got
destroyed in the Super Bowl
we were a wild card and that's why we
beat the Jets and then the next week we
beat look at me with a memory beat the
Jets and then we beat the Raiders and I
went down to the the airport in
Providence Rhode Island and it was like
me and like only 70 other people at this
point you know and we met have all the
players as they got off the plane all
the old school guys Julius Addams I
remember somebody reaching over and
slamming him really hard on his shoulder
like hitting him way too hard and he
[ __ ] looked at me like I did it and I
was like I wasn't knew the guy behind me
but I was the first time I saw a bunch
of athletes up close
Tony Eason completely expressionless I
remember he was wearing a butterscotch
Members Only jacket I swear to God and
he looked like he was on his way to Home
Depot and right then I should have known
that he was going to get crushed in the
Super Bowl but I would say that you know
what Bruins games the first Bruins games
I went to the Boston Garden
they always go to Bruins Canadians
actually went to that bench-clearing
brawl if you go on YouTube it's the one
where Chris Nilan
I was at the game where he hit Rick
Middleton in the teeth with his stick
and then as he was walking off that's
right he walked off the ice and then he
pushed ten lindeman who chased him down
and next thing you know there was a
bench-clearing brawl and Terry O'Reilly
in his suit was grabbing on to somebody
and never mark what for I was good time
all right I'm just babbling here I just
wait for my plumber 1020
three [ __ ] still down here okay
Wow I'm getting bored with myself here
number five what do you think of the
comedy genre anti humor like the type by
Neil hamburger and Ted I don't know
those guys I watched them and they seem
funny to me you know I don't know it's
not anti humor is it I don't know who
gives a [ __ ] alright so I was watching
one of using - who's throwing food at
you I already answered that that's a
doughnut it's a doughnut hole you see
the video on my page was a group of
people they were advertisers they all
worked at the same place I started
thrashing them and they threw a doughnut
hole at me and evidently I didn't give a
[ __ ] number 7 when you have these
horrible thoughts about people are you
able to keep your face stoic mine
wrinkles up and I don't notice until the
person looks at me if so how do you play
it off no I'm usually cursing like what
I think is under my breath but out loud
and then they look right at me I
literally walked through like an airport
go and look at this [ __ ] guy what
kind of shirt is that and I think I'm
kind of doing it in my head a whispering
but I'm saying it loud enough that they
look right at me and then I look away
which is pretty pathetic okay which is
you know what this podcast is getting
pathetic is way too long let's get the
thing okay my DVD don't put off the big
announcement is going to be coming out
in September of 2008 and the my DVD my
one-hour special will also be shown on
Comedy Central in September of 2008 so I
have all summer to write some to write
some new jokes but you already have
already got a whole new Lauer so alright
this podcast
how many minutes is this yeah this
podcast is really [ __ ] long and I
didn't get to have to [ __ ] I want to
talk about I want to tell you guys how I
was back to drinking Budweiser I've come
full circle actually I started off with
Michelob light then it quickly went to
Budweiser and then throughout the years
I switched to vodka then I ended up with
[ __ ] Johnnie Walker Black and now I'm
right back to Budweiser again and I
guess that was the moment
at the Johnny Walker Black where I was
supposed to admit that I had a problem
and stop cold turkey but evidently I'm
going to run the cycle all over again
and go back and start dating from the
same psychos that I dated you know what
next week I'll tell you the story about
me getting arrested for drinking and
driving back in [ __ ] June
well December of 1989 was on my way back
from Boston College and go watch the
Patriots play [ __ ] the Los Angeles
Rams as I had season tickets who knew
they were going to be 5 and 11 from
anyways so that's the puck you know it
started off [ __ ] it started off
strong
I was trashing the art of plumbing and a
dead Karen Carpenter and then it just
sort of tapered up you know and I don't
happen I should have [ __ ] quit while
I was ahead but anyways thanks to
everyone who listened to these podcasts
I really appreciate it and if you would
actually you know something if you enjoy
my podcast could you please let people
know about them because you know I burn
up a lot of minutes every week on my
[ __ ] cell phone I'm getting brain
cancer and I'm talking to like 15 people
and I'd like to break 20 if I could get
it up 20 people before June 10th when I
turned 40 that would make me feel a
whole lot better all right so thanks to
everybody who who's been listening and
sorry to all the Karen Carpenter fans
I'm sorry to people who are plumbers
actually know what I'm not sorry
okay I'm not [ __ ] sorry because one
of your I'll be sorry when some you guys
from the plumbers Union have a little
talking to
it's 10:20 [ __ ] 7:00 I started this
podcast at 10:03 so there's a 24 minute
podcast I was hoping that the guy was
going to walk in during the middle of it
we could have a little reality show
moment but he did you don't probably
have me far as walked up halfway through
the stairs and heard me bitching about
[ __ ] plumbers on my podcast and
didn't hear me talking to anybody so you
thought I was crazy or I was berating my
wife my non-existent wife oh look at the
gloom look at the [ __ ] bloom out the
window
all right that's it so why please come
out to see me Chicago with Janie's this
week or Caroline's in New York City at
the end of the month or at goodnights in
Raleigh North Carolina or the punchline
in Atlanta Georgia next month
I'll write you [ __ ] I have a CD
up on iTunes called emotionally
unavailable the expanded edition why
don't you go there buy it buy it for a
friend
buy it for a plumber [ __ ] break the
CD in half stab him in his jugular he's
late and that's it that's the Monday
morning podcast I'll talk to you next
week
[Music]
Oh
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you